I've been craving Nando's all throughout my pregnancy.
When I found out they had a location close to us,
I made lucky get in the car and drive us there.
I've been to a lot of Nando's locations all over the world,
so I'm really excited to try out this one.
Favourite one was in South Africa, so see how this one compares.
We looked at the menu, then lucky placed our order and paid.
You got two different lemonades?
Mine was a mango orange one which was so good.
And then he got a lavender one which was very strong but very good.
Shortly after our food came out,
lucky immediately knew that we had to order some more
cause it was not enough food for him.
We got the chicken thighs,
halloumi, peri peri fries, and chicken legs to share a salad,
and got the kids some Mac and cheese.
I took a few bites,
I looked over and lucky was already done with his plate.
Oh, he was thinking of what he wants to order.
I tried the salad.
The salad was very mediocre.
I didn't really like it.
But the Brussels sprouts were so good.
Peri peri fries could have been a little crispier, but we ate it all,
stacked the plates, and then ordered round two.
We just got our favorite things again.
Honestly, the peri peri sauce isn't as spicy as I thought it would be.
Even the hot was kind of mild.
Picked out All the Brussels sprouts without the ranch on top,
because lucky doesn't like creamy sauces.
And we wrapped it up.
Needed something sweet after,
so we got some ice cream.
They had the most interesting flavors.
We taste tested a bunch and then decided on what we were gonna get.
Lucky got guava and olive oil,
while I got vanilla and.
And raspberry lychee.
I love the combination of getting a sorbet and something creamy.
Always do it. It's so good.
This was perfect.